marceia is a more perfect union names to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us we
introduced you this morning to a young
woman who's taking on bullying more than
20% of kids say they've been bullied in
middle school or high school a lot of
bullying happens at lunch Jamie yuccas
met the teenager who's working to put an
end to it
one cafeteria at a time lunchtime
bullying you're gonna eat this is a
common Hollywood plotline but it's also
a painful reality in school cafeterias
throughout the nation I was ostracized
by everyone I ate lunch alone every day
I was pushed into lockers I was sent
threatening emails a reality Natalie
Hampton now a high school senior in
California knows all about I was
physically attacked three times in two
weeks and I came home sobbing with
bleeding red scratch marks Natalie
eventually switched schools but the
memories of those years of torment stuck
with her so many people walked back and
forth in front of my table and all I
wanted to hear was hey are you okay come
sit with us
those four words come sit with us
sparked an idea and eventually an app if
you go to the search tab it gives you a
whole list of the lunches that you can
join in your school without any fear of
rejection she created the sit with us
app free to download private to use it
connects kids in need of company with
welcoming students the app now has over
a hundred thousand users in eight
different countries giving Natalie a
megaphone for her message I began to
think she's become an outspoken leader
of the anti-bullying movement speaking
at conferences she even gave a TED talk
I was seen for the first time in two
years and it saved my life the app and
it's message to be inclusive is
inspiring other students like eighth
grader Lola Clark
she created a sit with us Club at her
school since they don't allow cell
phones why do you think people join
because they will have a place to sit I
won't you love them and they know here
they can be accepted not judged and they
can have a really good time no I was
never like exactly the same as everyone
else
: Brainerd is one of the club's members
and sit with us there's people who sort
of you can connect with if you're a
little different and you can feel like
you're a part of something do you feel
different in school I don't feel like
different in a bad way I feel different
in a good way
for Natalie Hampton the success of sit
with us has given her a new purpose
but you guys favorite TV shows uniting
fellow students one lunch period at a
time using my story to help others has
given me strength and confidence that I
never knew that I had I mean it's seven
for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles I am all for
apps that promote kindness and
acceptance in grade school and beyond no
good Congrats to her